eca send them membres du collectif des
précaires de l'hôtellerie et
restauration événementielle bon soir à
saint nazaire merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur la france on vient de vous
voir vous exprimer aujourd'hui
clairement comment qualifieriez-vous
votre situation de catastrophique
bonsoir madame devenue catastrophique
parce que le gouvernement il a mis à la
marge de la société plus de deux
millions de personnes
la mission principale de l'état et de
les protéger
et malheureusement le gouvernement n'a
mis aucune mesure d'urgence pour
protéger toutes ces personnes au jour
d'aujourd'hui en a comme réponse que du
mépris du déni de l'ignorance de la part
du gouvernement
c'est pour cela que nous mettons toutes
nos forces afin de afin de sensibiliser
la classe politique le gouvernement pour
qu'il prenne en charge l'autre situation
clairement vous vous considérez aussi
aujourd'hui comme des laissés pour
compte c'est vrai que beaucoup de
secteurs la moitié des salariés du privé
étaient au chômage partiel
aujourd'hui vous êtes vous les laissés
pour compte
c'est là exactement en se considère en
se considère comme étant déçus citoyens
parce que l'état comme je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure dans sa principale fonction
est de protéger ses citoyens
eh ben ils ont absolument rien fait le
gouvernement n'a proposé aucune aucune
solution à notre problème n'a mis aucune
mesure d'urgence sauf s'ils considèrent
le rsa comme étant une mesure d'urgence
nos par contre en a mis des propositions
sur la table
on a eu dernièrement qu initié avec 14
autres collectifs à une nouvelle réforme
de l'assurance chômage qu'on a mis sur
la table qui est basée sur deux études
solide à savoir celles de l'unédic et
celle du sociologue mathieu grégoire qui
disent on est seuls mots que cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage est une
catastrophe sociale en coin justement
elle est pour vous à saint nazaire
cette réforme de l'assurance chômage en
quoi elle va particulièrement
expliquez-nous vous pénalisez alors vous
sachiez que l'assurance-chômage dans
calade de vos liens le premier volet il
a été actée sans l'accord des
partenaires sociaux en novembre 2019 le
gouvernement à passer en force et à ce
premier volet déjà il a eu un impact
très négatif sur les entrants à à
l'assurance chômage
sachez que chaque mois il ya plus de
vingt mille personnes qui sont éjectés
de l'assurance chômage pour insuffisance
de droit al'inverse que al'inverse il ya
200 à 300 personnes de sont indépendants
et trois cent dix missionnaires à
laquelle laquelle maria puis du co se
targue c'est une fierté pour elle mais
il ya vingt mille personnes qui sont
vraiment éjecté de l'assurance chômage
chaque mois je vous laisse faire le
calcul
et au jour d'aujourd'hui à plus de 400
milles personnes qui se retrouve sans le
sou s'ils ont la chance ils ont le rsa
le 1er septembre il ya le deuxième volet
qui va rentrer en jeu et ça ça touche là
le calcul de l'indemnité journalière et
là ça va être une catastrophe ça être
dramatique parce que on va se retrouver
avec des seuils en deçà du rsa alors le
secteur de l'événementiel et le vôtre
est totalement à l'arrêt l'hôtellerie et
la restauration reprennent tout
doucement
quelles solutions concrètes vous espérez
aujourd'hui la solution concrète situe
le gouvernement accepte nos
revendications on demande la même chose
que nos amis du monde du spectacle
as à savoir le gel de nos indemnités
journalières qu'on ait eue nabeul une
année blanche comme nos amis du monde du
spectacle
on demande l'annulation pure et simple
de cette réforme de l'assurance chômage
on demande un moratoire sur l'assurance
chômage qu'on réunisse les experts les
plus compétents pour en parler de cette
nouvelle réforme de l'assurance chômage
et qu'on est l'humain au coeur du projet
et qu'on arrête de nous prendre pour un
tableur excel pour des chiffres qu'on
manipule
merci beaucoup à saint nazaire d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
pour évoquer votre situation
et